you can think about the goals that you
have and say okay so if I want to go to
the gym how do I make it as easy as
possible for me to do that well I
probably wouldn't pick a gym that's far
away I would probably pick one that has
a lot of convenient hours I'd probably
pick one that has trainers and people
that I already like right you see what
I'm saying here so the friction is the
thing that you attack to make it easy so
that you can accomplish the quote hard
goals that only look hard to other
people who didn't make it easy for
themselves and so I think that is one of
those easy life hacks that a lot of
people underestimate is that they make
it hard to achieve hard goals when just
think about all the friction points that
you have between you and what you want
to do and remove them so it makes it
easy to hit the goals that you want like
no one's a superhero we just try to
stack the deck in our favor and I think
if you take that notion of make it easy
as possible to work as hard as you can
and frame it in reference to your goals
you'll hit a lot more your goals and
you'll be surprised what you can
accomplish